hmm okay so we got the opener for series
Henkes open up for series 6 let's get
going
[Applause]
[Music]
The Impossible Astronaut in the day of
the moon so we open series 6 with a
two-parter a bold start for a Doctor Who
series the show hasn't opened with a
two-parter prior to this so that's uh
that's a bold statement and given the
nature of this story this two-parter
it's a pretty bold two-parter as well
now I've always enjoyed this one but I
have not rewatched it in a while and re
watching it now huh I think once I wrap
up Smith's run I may have to devote a
video to sorting out how much or how
little sense some of the overarching
stories actually end up being
specifically when it comes to the
silence which frustrates me because I
actually really like the silence for a
number of reasons I'll come back to that
in a minute but I'm not gonna dwell on
this here because like I said it's I'm
working out from memory until I finish
the rewatch so but watching this now
there's a lot of stuff I'm like does
that ever get explained do we ever find
out about that they're really setting up
for something that if it has an answer
you don't remember it and if it does I'm
sure it comes way late so there's a lot
of that going on but that's not
something I am going to hold against
this particular story at least not in
this review because I'm dealing with the
thing basically as I saw it at the time
which is taking it as his own and has an
opener here now that doesn't mean I'm
not gonna take into account anything
that happens later just that I'm not
fresh enough on it to know how well or
badly everything actually holds together
big-scale so we have the very fun
opening of the doctor trying to get the
ponds attention by basically being
annoying enough to be written into the
history books
several points collects them and river
they go on a picnic seems kind of
innocuous and then the next Ranaut comes
out of the lake and kills the doctor and
then goes back into the lake and then
the doctor shows up again this one
younger than the one they just saw died
they can't tell him what's going on but
they know they need his help
suddenly the back in 1969 they're
working with Nixon they uncover the
silence and then day the moon is very
much dealing with how the heck do we
combat something we can't even remember
so there's a lot going on in this
two-parter we've got a ton of story a
ton of concepts a ton of craziness and I
can definitely see where or at least
thinking back the fact that there was a
week between these two episodes probably
did them some favors because watching
them back-to-back it's an odd transition
because the first one ends with Amy
appearing to shoot the astronaut which
is this little girl that they don't know
who it is and then the next one opens
and Canton who we had met the previous
episode it appeared to be prepared to
help the doctor and the others is now
hunting them down and kill is hunting
the convenience down and killing them
and the doctor is captured now that's
that's a jarring transition from one to
the next and the downtime in between
probably helped a bit doing them back to
back
it doesn't no favors but it really does
especially in hindsight feel like a
super convoluted plan and I'm not
tightly sure why it required the faking
of deaths for Amy Rory and River that
said for how convoluted the plan appears
to be if they were going to do this it
probably was a better idea to basically
just jump in
in the middle of the plan rather than
watch every step up to this point
because then it will probably make you
even less sense so I mentioned the
silence earlier on let's examine the
silence first off I love the design of
the silence love it I've gotten it come
I've gotten a sketch of them commission
that cons I love the look of them that's
it like tiny nitpick I don't love that
when when the camera gets right up there
in kind of the hollow there is an actual
I there's an actual sort of iris you
know up hidden up in the shadows of
there and I wish there wasn't I wish
that it was just this hollow or not
quite hollow but like this pit where I
should be I would have preferred that I
also I almost said I don't think they
need the lightning powers I think it's
fine that they have the Lightning powers
I think the way in which those got
debuted was ill-advised I think that
debuting those with them killing this
random woman in the bathroom
for no reason that I can figure out at
all they just do it like there's no
reason that that scene couldn't have
played out that the woman just leaves
the bathroom and Amy's there stunned and
the interaction with the thing is
otherwise largely unaltered and then the
debut of the fact that they have
lightning powers could have come at the
climax when they all have to escape the
ship and suddenly these things start
firing lightning out of their hands and
it could have been a real big whoa I
didn't know they could do that moment in
the heat of battle as opposed to having
that dropped earlier on in a slower
creepier moment and it kind of actually
diffuses the tension a little bit
because at that early point we really
shouldn't have enough of a sense of what
they're on about and we really don't as
far as a plan or their intentions or
anything go but just the fact that we
suddenly now know one of the major
strings to their bow that early on I
don't think that was a good call as far
as overall structure goes but I've
always loved both the design of the
Khans
out of the silence I find the idea of
this thing that you forget as soon as
you're not looking at it to be very
scary
and even though functionally its gimmick
is very similar to the weeping angels
being the practical upshot of all this
is you can't look away from it because
if you do then it can kill you it then
it will kill you there's a couple of
differences the first is you're also not
safe while looking at it because the
silence is still perfectly capable of
killing you this is when you turn away
you won't remember that you are in
danger in the first place um and then it
is that other thing it is the messing
with the head because for me the
scariest stuff is mental screwing with
you
like things that make me tense our
paranoia films I I say over and over and
over again scariest movies I've ever
seen is invasion of the body snatchers
the 1978 version because it messes with
your head and who you can trust in who
anybody can trust and anything that
brings into question your perceptions of
the world itself when done well that
scares me a heck of a lot more than
living statues something messing with
your mind scares me you know mental
illness scares me not like people with
mental illness scare me but like what
can happen to a mind scares me dementia
scares me so you know something like
this that can just edit itself out of
your brain and we see like kind of the
ultimate upshot of that with God moved
poor guy who runs the orphanage holy
crap ya know I find that I find that
pretty scary I also think the resolution
on this is this is genuinely clever
resolution this is one of those instance
where I kinda gotta go Moffat I think
you were actually as clever as you
believed yourself to be as far as this
resolution goes as far as inserting you
should kill us all on sight into the
moon land
because I buy it when he says every
human being will at some point see this
cuz I think it's kind of true up to this
point and it makes sense to me that as a
piece of history you know even with the
species going forward that something
like that basically be a ubiquitous
viewing experience and then the idea
that the humans fight them off without
even remembering that they did it that's
great that's awesome I love that entire
resolution in that whole concept I think
it's really really cool um the Richard
Nixon thing is kind of funny
I wondered going back like did they over
humanize him not that you know I want to
paint Richard Nixon is like history's
greatest monster he wasn't but he was
more than just a mildly flawed
politician than me the man was was a
scuzzball and I liked that they had all
this going on at the start of his
administration I think that helped a
little bit and none of the stuff that
they did or brought him in for even
though when it was kind of fun none of
it in any way negates the stuff that he
would do while in office none of it is
counteractive or in any way undercuts
the kinds of things the man would go on
to do so I don't think it runs afoul of
the putting a putting a pleasant face on
an unpleasant person Trobe not not badly
it ain't not not bad enough to clock it
on my radar at the very least um trying
to think what else I wanted to bring up
up cantons great that that actor's very
good and you know the regular cast and
they're all great though the little girl
who just on the off chance that people
that people are watching these reviews I
do kind of do these releases to me
you've at least seen the episodes that
I'm talking about but just in case
anyone's like watching for the first
time in keeping up with me the the
little girl the twist at the end was an
interesting twist and I'm gonna be
keeping an eye
out for down the line um how did she die
and I'm asking that very sincerely
because it gets established in the
second part that Amy missed when she
shot at her
so when spoilers this little girl
regenerates at the end of the episode
it's not from the gunshot that Amy did
and I'm gonna keep an eye out for later
episodes to see if this ever gets
answered but I do not remember there
being an answer to why did she
regenerate and I it's not even
necessarily the kinds of things that I
things that I definitely need an answer
to but you drew my attention to it
and I kind of feel like I should know
that I mean was it just from escaping
the silence I suppose that just feels I
don't know a little weak but it is
little things like that that sort of
brick come back to what I mentioned at
the front end how well does this all
hang together
when taken within the scope of the
series and Smith's era as a whole I
don't know yet um and and there are
nitpicky things but the actors are all
doing really good I like the concept I
love the design of the silence
I love the resolution on this like I
will I will always call out Moffat when
he's being less clever than he thinks he
is but I'll also give the man the praise
when he nails it and with that
resolution at least I think he nailed it
but yeah this is gonna be an interesting
season for me to keep an eye on as we go
along series 6 premiere Impossible
Astronaut day of the Moon you rewatched
it lately what are your thoughts I know
whatever they are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it other
stuff you can do as well if you wish to
support this channel through pay
that would be immensely helpful even if
you don't you can always like subscribe
leave a comment and share this video it
helps grow the channel and appeases the
algorithm so there's all that stuff that
you can do plus links to other stuff
besides down in the description but you
also don't have to because at the end of
the day folks you're the council i'm
just running this meeting and until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]